is there
since you speak both languages is there
something that's lost
in translation to you is there something
you can express in italian that you
can't in english
and vice versa maybe is there something
you could say to the musicality of the
language
i mean i from i've been to italy a few
times and
i'm not sure if it's the actual words
but
it's the people are certainly very
there's body language too there's just
the whole being is language
so i don't know if uh you miss some of
that
when you're speaking english in this
country yes in fact
actually i certainly i i'm uh
i miss it and uh somehow it was a
sacrifice
that i made consciously by the time when
um
i arrived i knew that this i was not
going to express myself
i'm a better level and uh and
it was also sacrificed because uh given
to you ever also
your mother tongue is russian so you
know that
you can be very expressive in your
mother tongue and not very expressive
there's a neutron a new language and
then
what people think of you in the new
language because when the precise of
expression of things
it generates you know it shows a normal
elegance
or it shows you know knowledge or he
shows us a census or he shows us a caste
or an education whatever it is
so all of a sudden i found myself on the
bottom
yeah so i had to fight all my way up
back
up and but what i'm not saying i go back
to fascinating right
their limitations are actually our
strength in fact is a trick
to limit yourself to exceed right and
you know
there are examples in history if you
think about you know
goes to invade mexico he has what a few
hundred
people with him and uh he has a hundred
thousand people in arms on the other
side
first thing he does he limits himself
he sinks his own ship there is no return
okay and at that point he actually
managed
that's really good i i actually
first of all that's inspiring to me i
feel like i have quite a few limitations
but more practically
on the russian side i'm going to try to
do a couple of really
big and really tough interviews in
russian
uh once coveted lifts a little bit i'm
traveling to russia
and i'll keep your advice in mind
that the limitations is a kind of
superpower we should use it to our
advantage
because you do feel less
like you're not able to convey your
wisdom
in in the russian language because i i
moved here when i was 13
so you don't you know the parts of life
you live
under a certain language are the parts
of life you're able to communicate
you know i became i became a thoughtful
deeply thoughtful human in english
yes but the the the pain from world war
ii
this the the music of the people that
was instilled with me
in russian so i can carry both of those
and there's limitations in both
i can't say philosophically profound
stuff in russian
but i can't in english express like that
melancholy feeling
of like the people and so combining
those two also
beautifully said thanks for sharing this
is great yes i
totally understand you yes
you